so the Lux project is an incredible way
to bring together the diverse
collections across the cultural heritage
units at Yale it allows us to fulfill
our mission to Steward these objects
forever and for all people
you should think of Lux as a doorway it
is our way to share the opportunities to
explore and discover what we have Lux is
revolutionary because it's not just
another database it uses the same
Paradigm that major search engines do to
connect knowledge regardless of where
that knowledge is from there are lots of
different audiences for Lux and so when
I think about Lux I think of the student
here at Yale who will use Lux for
reasons of curiosity for the visitor Lux
is a way to imagine a visit at Yale that
would Encompass all of the incredible
cultural heritage collections I'm
remembering my days when I was a art
history student in New York working on
Charles schieler had I had Lux 20 years
ago I would have discovered the
monographs in the Haas Arts Library I
would discover the letters the
correspondence of Charles schieler in
the beinecke library the objects of the
artist Charles scheeler in the Yale
University Art Gallery in building
blocks we pay particular attention to
ensuring that the application is easy to
use by anyone regardless of age
background or any other Factor so when
you log on to Lux you can quickly search
for anything that you're interested in
is the simple search box put in a word
hit enter but you also have the ability
to do really complex searches using our
advanced search system each of us comes
to the kinds of questions we ask as
Scholars and researchers with a set of
biases and we don't know what we don't
know and what Lux can do for anybody
regardless of what they're working on is
allow them to see dimensions of an issue
a problem a topic that they just didn't
know existed so if you get interested in
a topic you're going to be able to
explore that go down rabbit holes come
out here see something that you've never
imagined before that changes the way you
think about what you thought you were
interested in Lux is light and we
welcome you to Lux to discover and to
fulfill your curiosity
[Music]
foreign